if this is our first wheat but it
doesn't feel like that at all there were
no first day of school jitters it feels
like we've been here for a long time
that's Johnny Galecki on the set of The
Big Bang Theory in 2007 dishing on how
he landed the role ten years after his
sitcom Roseanne rapped when Chuck called
me initially I was doing a play on New
York I was not actively looking for a
live audience show for a long time after
Roseanne just because just you just
showing I did it and I did it for five
years and want to kind of mix it up a
little bit and I did that and it was
great and well fans have come to know
and love Johnny as Leonard my name is
dr. Leonard Hofstadter and I could never
please my parents so I need to get all
my self esteem from strangers like you
but he's worse he was actually up for a
different role initially he said you're
gonna be playing Sheldon I said well I'm
really kind of more driven to this to
this character which I'm I don't even
remember why I said that at the time but
I'm glad I did because I couldn't I
can't hold a candle to what mr. Parsons
is doing in that role he's just so
incredible I have any chopsticks
you don't need chopsticks this is Thai
food here we go
Pilon has had the fork since the latter
half of the 19th century and prepping to
play a super genius on screen took a lot
of prep work yeah there's a fella named
David Salzburg who's a consultant a
technical consultant on the show he's a
physicist over at UCLA and we've gone
and spent face with him Jim and I did
and and then I think some of the writers
did after we came back and we learned a
ton of condescension maybe I didn't go
to college when I was 11 like you maybe
I got my doctorate at 24 instead of 16
but you are not the only person who is
smarter than everyone else in this room
no offense we didn't go with the
intention of kind of learning what these
characters know because that's just
impossible it takes a specific type of
brain you know so we didn't pretend that
we could walk away with anything like
that but you know as actors you just
kind of try to steal mannerisms or just
take negative wardrobe postures or the
interaction more than anything
oh honey minor up chief no sounds like
you up company oh they're not going
anywhere
Johnny also gushed over his co-star
Kaley Cuoco the only woman on the cast
at the time she said that she enjoys
that well we'll talk to her in a few
months but you know hanging out with
with the boys all the time but she she
enjoys it big sheets she she she likes
the adoration and deserves all of it and
he also opened up about his character
finding love I'm sure that there will be
a lot of stumbling and tripping on the
way oh honey so you're coming from work
that's great that you're home from work
how was work
well the Cheesecake Factory you know
people order cheesecake and I bring it
to him sweet
[Music]